no
vídeo de hoje eu trago 5 apostas
impossíveis de ganhar onde vocês podem
apostar algum dinheiro com os vossos
amigos ou familiares e vou ter sempre a
certeza que vão ganhar nesse caso eu vou
postar sem euros com todos os meus
amigos YouTubers neste caso eles não vão
postar nada mas eu pelo menos tenho que
não vou perder os senhores porque eu vou
fazer cinco truques impossíveis ganhar é
o primeiro truque Vamos começar com até
relativamente fácil vocês vão precisar
de quatro Palitos e uma carica Vamos
colocar os palitos em forma de paz mais
ou menos assim e a clica aqui dentro do
nosso amigo tem que retirar a carica de
dentro da paz sem tocar nela e apenas
pode mexer em dois palitos mas nunca
alterando a forma da parte vamos retirar
o Palito aqui do Centro que local aqui e
o segundo falei aqui dois palitos Só
pude festas a venda Só isso é muito
fácil tem que tirar e aqui dentro aí né
e só posso mexer dois dois palitos e
manter a forma da pa
e como
E aí
e o meu Deus não tem acreditar
e não mas é que eu tenho que mexer ele
também
[Música]
e
eu não pode ser tão difícil meu é que tu
dormir
eu não posso não
É mano é
[Música]
é dois palitos
do papá
tem mais fácil Essa é mais fácil então
mais fácil tenho que virar para o outro
lado
as melhores roupas Se eu fizer isso aqui
isso aqui não dá
e
as me chamar
E aí
e assim o branco já sabia é assim ó aqui
ó
Olá eu sou muito burro não é só funciona
assim
não é
[Música]
[Risadas]
E aí
a redundar Esta é para cá e isso vem
para cá
hahaha um palito dois palitos e
e o que vocês precisam para este truque
É de um copo 2 garfos e um palito e ele
sabe o que é equilibrar o Palito e os
gatos em cima do copo mas os gatos nunca
podem tocar aqui no copo tem que juntar
os dados desta maneira colocar o Palito
aqui no meio e aqui está a solução é só
colocar em os gatos desta maneira que
achar um ponto de equilíbrio com o
Palito Espera mais um pouco quando se
sentir assim
[Música]
E aí
o
seu palito já tá gás o Cusco os gatos
não podem ver muito grande como um copo
não de nenhuma forma e tenho que ficar
equilibrado equilibrados mesmo
e não
[Música]
E aí
o
caraças meu amorzinho pode ser chegando
aí
Oi Fran
e o
eu
vou fazer aqui uma
fica quase um
não dá mano
E aí
[Música]
e não pode ir
E aí
ah ah ah
[Música]
a minha filha da
quase o meu objetivo era tentar por
assim aqui dentro Ok é
e
assim conseguir por aqui por causa dos
pesos dos 21
eu
vou desistir mais não é
[Música]
e
olha olha sapatos isto não sei existe um
E aí
o clarão a saber se é assim que isso é
tão estupidamente fácil
a
moto fuck you
tu estás a ver mas eu estava a chegar lá
era com os gastos assim não
tá com nada não
buraco
ganhar
isto não acredito
cenário mano
vamos precisar de três copos de plástico
copo de vidro e três facas e Qual é o
objetivo você conseguir equilibrar as
três facas e um copo de vidro usando
apenas estes três copos com base
assim como é que foi lá
é
isso como não vou trocar a mesa eu posso
mexer não tem que estar assim como estão
aí
E aí
Ah mas isso umas horas não segura
só pode ser isso assim então como é
possível
E tens de equilibrar as três facas e um
copo e nesse passo
[Música]
o que faz a ligação dos copos meu
e não não
não eu não posso ficar aqui nos três
copos é a base de
o nível 1
e
eu tenho fica suspenso nada
[Música]
o
Brasil é
e não dá um Xero a
Hoje não dá
[Música]
eu
não sei
viu duas mesmo na pontinha não é
possível sustentar isto como é que vai
dar não vai dar não dá para mexer eu não
consigo isso é muito pesado Opá
é que eu não sei nem o que fazer eu
disse
e para isto
e
era posso fazer isso não
se você não fez isso
já percebi meu eu tinha que estava saber
mais ou menos maze a esta esta base da
Média 20 não pô
E aí
E aí o triângulo meio
é
mentira pula
pro baralho
a comprar em Porto isso não grande sabia
isso não pode ser verdade isso é muito
difícil Ok é isso O que é mais fácil não
estava a ler os senhores agora porque
este é realmente me fácil mas próximos
aqui duas garrafas de vidro e uma nota
no meio o objetivo é retirarmos esta
nota aqui do meio sem deixar de seguir
as garrafas a solução é simples mas
existe habilidade e
eu vou fazer uma oportunidade só tens
uma oportunidade e se conseguires ficas
com a tesoura e
E aí
a tocar está aqui também não tocar na
garrafa perdeste pergunto quem é
E aí
[Música]
Oi gata tá
e não pode colocar dois calma aí
E aí
[Música]
Oi Pera aí
muito
brutal e
e
não
perder se não acredito não gosta de mim
faz
perdeu para fora e
E aí
eu não acredito que agora é mais difícil
e o mais impressionante vamos precisar
de um martelo uma régua e uma cordinha e
o objetivo vai ser equilibrar estes 3
objetos mas temos duas regras régua é a
única coisa que pode tocar na mesa e a
régua tem sempre de estar por cima do
Martelo temos um nível assim esta é a
solução eu não sei se conseguem ver bem
daqui mas o Mateus está completamente
equilibrado aqui na régua e como eu
disse respeitando as regras a régua é
muita coisa que toca na mesa e o martelo
está abaixo da régua a única coisa que
pode tocar da mesa é a régua e a régua
tem que estar sempre por cima do Martelo
em casa
a
equilibrar isto
E aí
G1
Aí sim hein
[Música]
E aí
a
fazer isto
E aí
eu pego essa foto ficar assim eu posso
terminar aqui assim será ou não
[Música]
e não
tem que ter física muito complicadas
eu fui
eu vou deixar o rato puto Se tu
conseguir fazer assim
a calma
o amor é
é só minha cara mano enviar o margoso
[Música]
é super
eu
não sei lá
E aí
o
sorvete os tem a voar
oi oi
gente vai fazer agora para eu ver vou é
tudo que é uma Resistência é não dá
é impossível um
eu não faço ideia não faço ideia de
desistir mesmo uma vez quero saber a
relação Claro Como assim como é que tem
que fosse um
o
caraças e ainda melhor não isso não
isso é mentira não dá não tem porta
e não só truques e